-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Richard Kind,
everybody.
And we were talking about it.
You've got a lot of projects
coming up.
It's on Hulu.
People are telling me
it's fantastic.
-I hear it's hilarious.
Oh, jeez. Look at me.
[ Laughter ]
-This is "History of the World:
Part Two."
It's a Hulu series based on
the Mel Brooks film.
-This one is the story of
Jesus,
John, Paul, George, and Jesus.
[ Laughter ]
And yeah, it's hilarious.
It was hilarious to do.
I hear it's great.
And I spoke to your brother.
-Yeah.
-He said it's hilarious.
I can't wait to see it.
-And this is based on,
obviously,
the very famous Mel Brooks film.
Do you know Mel Brooks?
Is he someone you've been
lucky enough to know?
-Yeah, I have. There's
a couple of things.
First of all, at
the Kennedy Center Honors,
I sang "The Inquisition"
from "History of the World,"
so that was thrilling.
And there's Obama up there,
and I'm performing for
President Obama.
Then I did "The Producers"
on Broadway,
and then I did it at
the Hollywood Bowl.
So when Mel Brooks wrote
his autobiography,
there's a chapter about me,
"the very talented but loud
Richard Kind."
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
That's a very kind way --
-It's so lovely.
-I would say very talented
and loud.
I wouldn't make it a "but."
I would say these are two
great things.
-He might have,
and I will take it.
He might have.
-Yeah, okay.
-I thought I memorized it.
Hold on, hold on.
Listen to this.
-They're listening to
everything you're saying.
[ Laughter ]
-But this is important.
Okay, the other week,
about two weeks ago,
I have COVID,
and I told your guys,
so I sent the pictures.
So you'll see.
I was sitting in my room
in three-day-old pajamas,
haven't showered, hand down
the pants like Al Bundy.
[ Laughter ]
Just watching TV.
It's 4:00, it's probably 1:00
out in L.A.,
and I get a phone call.
"Hey, Richard.
Who do you think this is?"
I don't know.
Then I go, "Who do you think
this is?"
I don't know.
We go to FaceTime.
I get a phone call --
listen to this.
Mel Brooks, Norman Lear,
and Dick Van Dyke.
Mount Rushmore.
-It is Mount Rushmore.
-Are calling me,
and Judd Apatow,
who is I guess, FDR.
[ Laughter ]
Look at this!
-Look at your face!
-I know. I couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe it.
There's Mel Brooks.
-And here, by the way,
this is lovely.
This is all of them in the room,
and they called you.
Can I just say,
I am in awe of Dick Van Dyke
and his spryness.
All of them.
-They're all young and fit,
and there's all this food.
I would be like this
the entire time.
They're all sitting up
and talking,
which is why they're
thin and healthy.
But there's Mel Brooks.
Norman on his phone,
because Mel probably was
talking about
"History of the World,"
or they're gonna do "Producers"
in London
and my name came up.
I know Norman as a friend,
and so he probably said,
"Let's call him."
And out of the blue.
It is --
I'm gonna --
Don't listen to this,
'cause I haven't got the words
to describe
just how honored, touched
that I exist in that world.
-Those people, and I've been
lucky enough to meet --
and I've ever met Dick Van Dyke.
They are so warm and giving,
and they understand the value
of when they tell you,
"Keep up the good work."
When it comes from them,
my goodness.
-Right, well, I have met
Dick Van Dyke before,
the first time I met him.
I tried to tell him
the effect he had on me.
He would not let me talk.
He would just say,
"You're so good."
It's like he would stop it.
He put up an electric fence.
He wouldn't hear the compliment.
But I've told him since.
Mel will listen.
[ Laughter ]
-What a delight to
have you back.
I want you to know,
you're one of my legends,
and it is so lovely
to have you.
-It's so good to see you!
-You guys, Richard Kind!
"East New York,"
Sunday nights on CBS,
streams on Paramount Plus.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."